i mean
nothing lasts forever right
[Music]
so i'm going to talk about a topic that
i have not talked about
in almost four years
at this point so that is the idea of
superhero fatigue i have talked about
this once before if you want to see a
very old video
from before i was even out before i had
this hair or this kind of glasses or um
other things
about myself
but at the time i was talking about
superhero fatigue generally as a genre
and my basic premise at the time
was that so long as the majority of the
output is not
simply mediocre
then i
figured the genre had a lot of legs in
it because the specific tone of any
superhero movie can vary greatly just
look at how totally different the marvel
movies are from
the dc stuff and how totally different
the theatrical justice league is from
the zack snyder justice league so like
there's plenty of room
to do something unique
but my point in that video if you don't
feel like watching the whole thing was
ultimately as long as things don't hit a
background level of mediocrity because
even bad stuff can't really derail a
genre unless it's like almost all bad
because the bad stuff can put the good
stuff into sharp relief it's when it
starts to feel cookie cutter like
everything is basically hitting the same
basic level of unexceptional competence
that's where things get rough
now
this time i'm not going to talk about
superhero fatigue in general i want to
talk specifically about the idea of
marvel fatigue and i'm not approaching
it from the same angle as i did four
years ago shocking i'm a different
person now with different ideas while i
don't disagree with that old video i
never really
indulged the notion of marvel fatigue
specifically very seriously
until disney plus day happened and we
got the full announcement of all the
stuff they've got coming out so
this like and this is not even going to
be a complete list i know i'm going to
miss some stuff here disney plus day
brought us teaser trailers for stuff we
already knew was happening so that
included moon knight she-hulk and ms
marvel it included announcements uh and
logo debuts and things like that for
spider-man freshman year agatha the
house of harkness there's going to be a
marvel zombies series there's going to
be another season of what if they are
going to revive the 90s x-men cartoon
and they are already working on a
spin-off for a character from hawkeye
which hasn't even aired yet at the time
that the announcement hit
so
that's on top of all the other stuff
that we know is in some degree in the
works we know there's going to be some
sort of i am groot i think it's a
holiday special there's gonna be that at
some point down the line they're working
on a wakanda series there's a lot of
stuff
and this has me worried in a way that
marvel films
don't because the thing is
with
movie releases
you're not only competing with yourself
you have to find a window in the release
schedule where you are not going to go
up against something that is going to
eat out of your audience base on the
weekends that it's out or at least you
want to avoid that as much as possible
obviously mult especially during
blockbuster season movies stack up and
pile up but it's very typical for
big movies in similar genres with
similar feels to really try and avoid
each other if they can because they're
going to cannibalize each other's
audiences so even as the number of
marvel movies coming out every year has
increased and now we're sort of looking
at a world where there's going to be
four maybe even five marvel movies a
year
that is still
a two to three month gap
between releases and while the movies
may linger in theaters long enough that
that theoretically you could see one
movie that has been in theaters for a
month month and a half and then a few
weeks later see a brand new movie and
they feel very close together
since the big push is always for the
initial
debut in the premiere weekend it doesn't
feel quite as crowded
but we're starting to look down the
barrel of marvel shows on disney plus
that are
piggybacking immediately off each other
that's kind of what we actually have
already dealt with to a certain amount
just this year because we had one
division lead almost immediately into
loki lead almost immediately into what
if we got a little bit of a breather
between what if and hawkeye but
honestly
every time one of those ended i remember
thinking oh okay i can get a what
there's another one oh crap now granted
my perspective is slightly skewed
because i talk about this stuff for my
job so i do actually have a higher sense
of obligation because i've got financial
interests
um you know involved in actually seeing
and talking about these things but i
don't think i've completely lost my
perspective of what it's like just to be
a fan and feel like well i want to know
and i want to be involved and i want to
see all this stuff but
you're not giving me a break
and i'm worried a little bit
about
the disney plus stuff in particular now
in some ways the fact that most of this
is all getting shoved onto disney plus
is a good thing because and i've said
this
for always i said this like way back
when people kept expecting
the uh the netflix marvel movies to er
not marvel movies marvel tv shows to
impact the movies or for ages of shield
to be acknowledged in the films and i've
always said like look the movies get
more people to see them
that has always been the case and while
the shows will be built off the movies
the movies
won't be built off the shows not in a
way that absolutely requires you watch
the shows
i think we will start to see increasing
times where you'll feel a bit more in
the know but i will be shocked if marvel
ever starts making movies that you
cannot understand unless you've been
watching the shows because the audiences
are not as big they're just not
so you're limiting your audience size
so by doing the big deluge of stuff in
the uh space of disney plus effectively
in television for all intents and
purposes
that does keep it from
basically sort of uh trampling on the
movies
again unless they
get
dumb and start making uh watching the
show's essential viewing to
understanding the movies
so like my my primary example for how i
expect this to play out we are going to
get another captain america movie it is
going to have
sam as captain america it is going to be
built off of the show captain america
and the winter falcon
uh
what captain america
the falcon and the winter soldier
they just came up with like a fanfic
parody or something
ah the new captain america will be built
on the back of the falcon and the winter
soldier tv show however i
have no doubt in my mind
that the way it's going to be presented
is a way that will still flow off of the
end of end game so that if you watch it
following the end of end game and that
ending had bucky and sam kind of
together and sam accepting the shield
you watch the next captain america where
he is captain america you go okay
in the interim between these movies he
came to terms with wielding that shield
cool
if you have watched the show you saw
that play out but it's a general
trajectory that makes sense even if you
didn't watch the show that is the way in
which i expect these to relate to the
movies
so the movies aren't necessarily going
to be the issue but even when separating
them and putting it on disney plus and
putting it in an environment that
it you don't have to worry about bumping
against about up against other stuff as
much because it's all going up on
entirely your own platform
this still feels like a lot
and
i don't
i think part of what's throwing me off
at least
is that right now disney's
major brands
have all moved to disney plus
like pixar's doing multiple tv shows
they've had movies actually debut
on disney plus
the star wars stuff now that they don't
have much going on with the movies i
guess rogue squadrons still happening
but
star wars is largely relegated to disney
plus marvel yeah still has movies but
all this new stuff is here and like i
don't even know what's airing on the
actual disney channel like on television
proper anymore or disney xd
it's that seems to be where actual
original stuff goes like your owl houses
amphibia etc
but they seem to have put all the big
branded stuff on disney plus which from
a business perspective does make sense
because
that's going to push the um the growth
they wanted to launch it as strongly as
possible and
you know leveraging your strongest
brands to not do that would be stupid
so i get that
but at this point it's just so much
and
i think
there is a danger i think of marvel over
saturation
on disney plus specifically
again
i expect things to be separate enough
that for the most part it won't impact
the movies but there may still be some
knock-on effects because
if the really dedicated fans the ones
who tune into disney plus and watch
everything like me
and i would have done even if it wasn't
my living at this point
are we going to be exhausted of marvel's
stuff by the time the next movie comes
out and maybe not rush out to see it
opening weekend
maybe wait for it to hit streaming
maybe just
decide uh i don't need to see it right
away i don't know
maybe we will but this is not a fear
that i would have had or a notion i
would have indulged at all
you know even four months ago
but now
it is starting to feel
more like
homework
again that's partially my perspective
having to watch it um
i like i suspect left 100 of my own
devices and without
um reviews and thoughts on it being
expected of me by my audience i might
give like say a second season of what if
a pass
i'd probably give marvel zombies a pass
i'm not gonna say it's impossible for me
to bail on these things if i really
don't like them but i feel obligated to
at least give them a shot
so maybe that perspective is skewing
things
because
i don't know to what degree people who
don't talk about this stuff for a living
feel an actual obligation
i'm sure there is to some degree some
kind of fan obligations that they
certainly want you to feel they want you
to feel like you have to watch
everything but eventually
i think most people will hit a point
where they're going to go
nobody don't actually need to watch all
of this
and i think we'll start to see
i think what while what i hope because i
i like marvel i like the mcu i like the
marvel products i've i loved most of the
movies i've enjoyed two varying degrees
most of the tv products some more than
others
but
that does not mean i want them to just
go on in perpetuity and dominate
absolutely everything non-stop because i
do need other things in my life and when
you start filling the world with so much
marvel stuff that it feels like i don't
have time for anything else and again
from a business perspective i actually
understand disney wants you to stay on
their platform it doesn't want you on
other people's platforms but like at a
certain point it starts to feel coercive
and not like a healthy fan relationship
and i think or what i hope we will see
is that
interest in
certain parts of this will start to
dwindle if i'm being honest it'll
probably be the animated stuff which
won't be entirely fair
but is i would say it's likely like
there's a reason that what if was
animated the way that it was because the
method of animation they chose is a heck
of a lot faster and cheaper
than either
fully properly rendered 3d uh animation
or 2d hand-drawn they rode the middle
ground in the pocket of it being faster
and cheaper
so
i think they already know this
and so i what i kind of suspect is that
give it
a year two years
and we'll start to see a drop off
because like maybe fans
will watch a whole bunch of first and
second episodes and then realize
i've got other things to do and then
there'll be drop-offs and whatever those
shows are we'll see less of what we'll
see less of them going forward
and if i were to
pick what is likely to be the be dinged
i think it's going to be a the animated
stuff like i said and b
things like echo and like house of
agatha
the spin-offs of the shows that we
already got because like these things
had a strong launch out of the gate
because they were bringing in the movie
characters
and while uh it makes for a
theoretically stronger ongoing um
pool of resources and characters to work
from do not have to pull in the movie
actors for everything
when you start doing the spin-offs of
the thing that you already had to kind
of sell us on by bringing in the bigger
names and now you're giving us the
spin-off without those bigger names i'm
not going to say it can't work
but if something's going to taper off i
think it's going to be those
and then if i were to take my most
possible pessimistic view the long-term
most pessimistic
pessimistic option that i would have
would be that
eventually they start to realize that
the only thing that is doing well enough
for it to be worth it for them are the
ones that involve the movie actors and
characters
but that they can't afford to keep
putting them on tv because
you know people like paul bettany and
elizabeth olsen and anthony mackey and
sebastian stan
they command higher prices
than the stars that they've got lined up
for same ms marvel
so
i don't think they'll ever stop
producing marvel stuff for disney plus
that won't happen but i will not be
surprised if after a year two years
it tapers off after this initial
explosion this feels like
throwing everything at the wall to see
not
not throwing it off the wall to see what
sticks in a we don't know what works way
but more of a you know what we've got
their attention
throw everything and let's figure out
what's worth keeping
so normally when you say throw
everything at the wall and see what
sticks it's an implication that people
have no idea what they're doing i think
they know what they're doing
and i would not be surprised if an
eventual rolling back and tapering back
of the extent of all this
is actually part of the plan
but we'll see because it does feel like
a lot right now
and this is the first time i've indulged
the idea of marvel fatigue in anything
other than a thought exercise that i
thought it might actually happen
that's kind of where i'm at with this
what do you think are you already
fatigued i've heard from some people who
are do you think you will be do you
think you can't be
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it like share subscribe i
have a patreon
that's how i'm able to afford things
like disney plus and do this as my
living any amount you're able to help is
of great assistance and appreciated but
don't worry too much at the end of the
day you are the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelin robin moore ross schultz shayla
gourlay wanna hear me mispronounce your
name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]